okay so today we're rainy starts bad
finish I spend a lot of time on him
Epictetus and we're going to talk about
a different ancient philosophy that
always you have appearance in ancient
times once you know the Hellenistic age
started and then it kind of went into
decline or we can absorb by a lot of
Christian plot and then I've got a
resurgence in the modern period went
back into the client a bit and then it's
have new resurgence again in our
contemporary in your lifetime stoicism
is starting to catch bad guys yeah as a
way of doing things I'm going to talk a
little bit why tell you a little bit why
that's the case and how that's turned
out that way but I want you to as we do
often I want you to think about these
questions and write down some responses
to them and we're going to use as
examples during this class I want you to
think about what has been pollution of
any minor this is what has been a major
disappointment in your life so far well
lived at least 18 years some things have
not been corrected you can't some
setback some griefs some things that you
haven't gone the way that you wanted
them to hopefully a lot more good things
than the mad thing you've had something
that didn't go well so I want you to
think about you don't have to pick the
worst one but just think about something
that really had to you and then think
about a recent minor annoyance because
I'm willing to bet that over break there
was at least one thing that ticked you
off irritated you annoyed you everybody
can think of something like that
equipment just a drain not running on
time it could have been
having to take the midterm you know
anything like that right and then I want
you to think about what is something
that you have been very happy about or
something that has made your life much
better it could be something that you
still experience now it could be
something that you just remember it
could be something that you did it could
be something that somebody did for you
any of those sorts of things we're going
to use those as examples and try to look
at that in the way that happiness look
at them let's see whether it's rational
so while you're doing that what is the
key question that Epictetus starts with
what is in our control he and he takes a
position that's different than a lot of
other people as a matter of fact he's
taking a position it's different from
say Aristotle or Plato people that we've
studied so far this semester not not
totally different there are some ways in
which they agree but there's other ways
in which they disagree why is he asking
that question well it all comes down to
this issue of freedom or freedom and
that is the thing that the Stoics a
really focused on you know and we would
use this word stoic in our vocabulary I
think all of you for the term and stoic
somebody has a stoic demeanor we mean
that they're not affected by things so
we often think of the athletes as being
stoic or military people under fire is
being stoic if they don't
great run away people who have to deal
with difficult situations medical people
or in the ER and they don't freak out
when they see all that blood and all the
other stuff that comes along with
emergency situations they have a stoic
demeanor we often think of a stoic as
maybe a little bit detached as not
compassionate not letting themselves
[ __ ] get involved with other people even
when they are involved with other people
why is that the case well we have a
certain image of a stoic that comes from
the actual stories this was a philosophy
stoicism that goes back in certain ways
to to Socrates Plato wasn't the only
person an aerosol wasn't the only person
in schools can trace themselves to
Socrates the Stoics traits themselves
back through a bunch of different
intermediaries and then the guy who
actually starts the stoah the Stoics is
this guy Zeno so now there's people who
study after him and eventually we get
down to by the time that epictetus is is
studying stoicism and advancing and it's
been around for quite a while and he's
actually a former slave being a slave in
the Roman Empire was not in a really a
treat it's not quite the same thing as
what slavery was like over here in the
United States or in the Caribbean but it
wasn't a good way to live he's a slave
who got freed and then started you know
teaching philosophy he picked stoicism
out of the different philosophies in
part because it made the most sense for
his experience he saw it he has a guide
for living well
so the same question about what is going
to make us happy is being addressed by
epictetus but he has very different
answers than does Plato Aristotle it
really
freedom and figuring out what's what's
in our control so let's look at what he
says and then we'll look at some of your
examples and we'll think about this so
some things are in our control and
others are farms things that are in our
control our opinion how we see things
the judgments that we have about things
so you can think this is a great lecture
or a boring lecture that's that's within
your your control isn't it we often
don't think of it that way well it just
is the way it is and I perceive it that
way but we actually have control over
our opinions pursuit whether we go and
do things or not we have control over
that right remember we talked about this
with Aristotle on the voluntary and
voluntary if you see somebody of
somebody who's very attractive for you I
don't know
pick whatever who do we find attractive
you like movie stars and musicians
what's up are you trying to plant a
suggestion okay I'm all for
entrepreneurship you know I suppose you
could call that sort of romantic
entrepreneurship okay so think about
people that we find a track do we have
to get involved with them give a choice
about this always sometimes I couldn't
help myself
it's that really true even if somebody
actually we talked about this if
somebody holds a gun to your head do you
have a choice yeah you have a choice to
say on you know not going to do what you
say anyway so pursuit desire and
aversion this is where it gets really
interesting little thing first what do
you mean by inversions we all know what
we mean by desire if you're averse to
something it's sort of like the opposite
of desire so how many of you have
headaches
once in a while do you like headaches
anybody wants a headache when you have a
headache you probably do it just about
anything you can't get rid of it right
how do we usually do it take some pills
maybe you like aspirin or sitting
benefit or ibuprofen I don't know what
else would you take like morphine or
things like that but that's probably
getting yourself in more trouble than a
headache is worth but where you drink
afterwards what happens another headache
right you reversed a headache what else
our University what do you try to stay
away from anybody here who likes other
kinds of pain some people like paying
alright masochist I'm not going to ask a
masochist but most people avoid pain
what else to be a client what else are
you guys averse to anybody like being
embarrassed
no nobody nobody wants to be embarrassed
in public though we're averse to that we
don't like that that debt you know
doesn't just hurt our feelings that sort
of bruises them doesn't know you don't
like having your feelings hurt either
you don't like people getting in your
way when you're trying to do something
you don't like when you're already
frustrated people talking to you or
telling you about stuff that you're not
interested in you know like getting on
the train and having somebody who you
don't like wanting to start a
conversation with you alright we're men
do you do you like that anybody here
into that sort of thing some people are
but they're not so we have enough
versions to things and we also have
desires and we've talked a lot about
desire this semester so I don't have to
rehearse what you have desires for you
go you've probably thought quite a bit
at this point about what your desires
actually are you've probably started to
rank order your desires you know which
of your desires are actually more
important Epictetus is saying you have
control over those you have control
whether you desire something
and how much you desire so think about
the things you desire
Epictetus is right you don't have an
immediate control but you have some
degree of control over those so he says
what's not in our control body
everything having to do with your body
it's it's in your control to some extent
right let's think about the things that
make up our bodies look around the room
and when you notice about people your
fellow classmates what are distinctive
features
the clothes that there were okay and
every one of you chose the clothes you
put on right nobody dresses this morning
you're not 3 anymore you could not wear
clothes I suppose right you probably do
something a lot of trouble here at
Marist if you did that and it'd be a
foolish thing to do anyway because it's
raining and cold outside your body you
have some degree of control right do you
get a lot of control over your clothes
how many of you been frustrated with
something that you bought a couple of
months later or style do you have
control over them what's deeper than our
clothes so we that's good you looked at
the surface what else each other that's
a good one do you have any control over
that and you could wear platform shoes
you can make yourself taller it with
things like that I guess you could learn
a donor's you have a really good posture
and you had a couple of inches if you
kind of slouch a bit and if you're
really tall what it's how people
actually do slouch in part because they
want to hear what other people are
saying and that's what we did bad
posture but can you really control that
I mean I suppose if if you're tall you
could have at one point maybe you've
taken something to them slow your growth
if they say from smoking cigarettes or
drinking coffee when your kids it's
supposed to stunt your growth I don't
know if that's true
can you take anything to make yourself
taller human growth hormone I guess you
could you know keep feeding that to your
kid if you want them to be a monster
some parents have done that yeah yeah
system yeah hi wells mm-hmm that you can
change right to some degree yeah I mean
you can change it and then your roots
will show in about two weeks to do the
procedure wrong you can burn your hair
off change it to some weird color that
you really didn't want I've seen that
happen people what else so these are
good examples height hair color what
else is on your driver's license you can
change that all right get different
colored contacts skin color you can
change that to some degree your weight
yeah you know some control you have some
control over that as well right
something you know more and more basic
knowledge that you're gonna carry with
you your name okay I wasn't thinking of
that but that's a good one you can't
actually change your name legally you
can change it to crazy stuff asterisk
spacebar you can call yourself try
two people have done that you can change
your name to a number that's true then
you do have some control over whether
you are glasses or contacts working or
if you just adopt you if you don't find
that seeing stuff you can't go without
your glass that's a trick question
the right answer what's that your
birthday can't control that that's
that's done right well worn on that day
can't go back if you had a time machine
I suppose you could have the induce
labor earlier but there'd be all sorts
of paradoxes by your sex your gender you
can change that to a certain extent
right I mean we now have these gender
reassignment surgeries you can take more
moans and all that so maybe epictetus is
wrong maybe all these things actually
are in our control
well they are and they aren't I mean you
can change your address you can change
your living but is your is your scope
you can go anywhere you want to can you
I mean you could put anything down as
your address if you don't mind your mail
not getting to you somebody else getting
your mail but can you actually live
where you want to I don't want your
super rich you can change a lot of
things in minor ways but you can't
really what about your body can't you
change can you turn that time I'm 41
years old like I can't go back to
like like you guys do with organs that
are younger and working better and bones
that aren't you know developing you know
over time weaknesses and nails that
actually break quicker not what you can
do about that sort of thing
because you can't change the fact that
you're aging can you change any of your
vulnerabilities can you turn them for
like think about science fiction stuff
thanks men
you know like turned to steel that's
kind of a handy thing to have right I
mean if you wanted to go do dangerous
things would it be nice to have steel
skin but you can't do that in real life
Kenny that's out of your control as a
matter of fact your body is very
vulnerable think about the human bodies
compared to other animal bodies we feel
pain so much easier cats and then rats
can't like fall you know a few stories
and get up and they're not affected at
all what happens when you fall a few
stories might die or break your leg or
you know crack the ribs
sometimes you die yeah there's so many
different ways that the human body can
be affected like that
there's so many things that can go wrong
you don't have much control over what
else property you have control over your
property don't check for day if somebody
really wants to steal your stuff can you
stop them
maybe you could stop the first person
maybe kill set an example all right but
if anybody's really determined to take
your stuff probably security companies
tell you this it's not actually about
making anything perfectly secure it's
just about setting up obstacles to make
them you know spend their time on
somebody else rather than on you making
yourself my support can you suddenly
become rich overnight if you want
robbery but that's not totally your
control isn't winning the lottery if it
was I'd be rich will it what about your
property you know the things that you
have a lot of you have these laptops how
many of you had problems with your
laptop so one form or another I should
raise my hand you know sometimes it
slows down for some unexplained reason
or you know things like that
that's out of your control isn't it
that's very frustrating isn't it because
you expect the technology to work the
first time and to keep on working that's
why we have technology reputation do you
control your your own reputation do you
control how people see you what do you
think somebody's saying yes
what do you control whether I tell you
that yeah so if you don't want people to
think you're complete jerk you can avoid
acting with a jerk does that mean though
that nobody is going to say hey man stop
yeah Oh your your same stuff that entity
doesn't say but before we get to that
point let's think about whether we have
control over that this is a really
interesting issue to think about because
you guys are exposed in so many more
ways than students were at in my time
when I was on campus you know some
people that have a reputation for being
a drunk or being a good student or what
else sexually available criminals boring
big fun to have a party but that was all
confined to who you actually knew I
think you know some people have a
reputation around town to small town
probably noble of nowhere and so I heard
they have a reputation and they may have
had some role in acquiring the
reputation but for the most part other
people give you your reputation right
how are you guys more exposed
you guys are in online how many of you
are on Facebook only a few of them
that's all of your on Facebook right hey
hey I have a Facebook page and a
Facebook profile are any of you on other
things like LinkedIn or Twitter or other
social networks
that's your persona that's who you are
only now it's not just in the physical
space and and now it stays forever
right I mean Facebook owns everything
that you put up there and they can
access it anytime there are there are a
lot of students or get themselves in
trouble because they've got a view out
of nowhere in this case they post a lot
of you know things on Facebook that
maybe aren't great for public
consumption and they figure that only
their
can see it and then you know there are
ways to get a hold of people's Facebook
information and employers routinely look
through Facebook profiles see if this
person is a big partier there you know
racist literature you know if they're
doing this or that that's part of your
reputation and you have some control
over that but not ultimately you don't
actually have control what else command
power do you have control over whether
you have power over other people yes
them no right I mean if you want to have
power over other people you can do it
pretty cheaply for a little while why
don't you actually have a great example
of this on the test so the easiest way
to get power over people temporarily go
to a restaurant right because anybody
who wants to be a jerk and lord it over
somebody can do it over their server
right if you if you have a power and you
need to feel like you're in control for
an hour or two go to a fancy restaurant
and start ordering people around and
they have to do what you want within
certain limits because they want to keep
their jobs and because they want to get
a tip from you there's lots of people
who act like real jerks I mean there's
very few people who go to restaurants
just deliberately to do that but they
often find themselves doing that but
aside from those sort of things do you
you have much control over you getting
political office or being put in charge
of the committee for this club or stuff
like that
what do you have to do if you want that
sort of thing if you want to get power
what do you have to do
you can be crass about if you laugh and
say things that I kiss a lot of behind
yeah you got to be convincing and that
means that you got to find out what this
person likes and with this person likes
and somebody's lying right making stuff
up attack your opponent even though
they're not a bad person do something
even then you might not win right and if
you get power does that mean that
everybody's gonna do what you say Howard
is often very disappointing you get the
fancy office and you get the people
under you and then you tell them what to
do and they don't do it so epic geniuses
is is onto something what's the big
difference between these things what
we're going to get to that and he gives
you gives you some examples he says for
example if you wish your children and
your wife and your friends to live
forever
you're stupid why because you want to be
in control of things that aren't in your
control you wish for things that belong
to others to be your own if you want
people to value you and to treat you the
way that you think you ought to be
treated that's not up to you is it
that's up to them and if you place your
happiness there you put your happiness
in somebody else's hands how much you
and that's a dangerous thing to do let's
think now about some of these these
things so what are let's start with the
happy stuff right what are some of the
things that made you guys can please
yeah Mitch over it okay good example
yeah seeing my family another good
example seeing your family take it yeah
i we have two dogs and two cats and this
is like the time of year where you want
to just curl up and sleep I wish I could
maybe you do too but you okay so those
are those are three good examples now
let's think about how those how
vulnerable those goods are taking a nap
what could interfere with that yeah
you're stuck in the dorms I don't know
if your dorms are like what dorms were
how does a college student they're not
easy places to take they're not even
easy places to sleep sometimes at 12
o'clock or 2 o'clock or are your dorms
better yeah they can wake you up where
they call you or they knock at your door
nothing you know it's kind of nice to
have friends but sometimes friends can
interfere with other things that you
want these are just minor ways or you
could worry about the stuff that you
have to do okay I've been seeing your
family how does that bother the family
could be out of sorts your travel plans
can be easily interrupted we don't have
to realize this because our travel
worked so well in the country but
there's so many things that go along
along the way or you could get home from
college and find out that you
as much in common with your family as
they used to this is a thing that often
happens at Thanksgiving people start
talking politics and they you know they
learn some things and they're they're
you know poli-sci class and then they
put them on the table and their parents
aren't so pleased right what was the
other / than your midterm grade you
could have done badly in your midterm
you could have a jerk professor who
wants to trip you up do you have control
over and you don't even know what to
tell midterm with some of these people
yeah you could have studied the wrong
material you could have what else could
have affected your major right you could
have gotten enough sleep the night
before through no fault of your own you
could have been sick all sorts of things
couldn't go out or not those those
things are vulnerable those are not in
your control if you're actually playing
a big penis instead if you're placing
your happiness of things like that he's
not saying that you shouldn't be happy
about getting a good midterm grade it
going to see your family or even you
know enjoying a good nap or like I did
last night watching a funny movie with
my my fiancee 21-7 bridesmaids and it
was sitting in Milwaukee which always
you know I like because I'm from that
area he's not saying you shouldn't take
any any joy in these but he's saying
that you should be very realistic about
this about how vulnerable these things
are but you should really be focusing on
is what is in your control and looking
to that to make you have not things that
are dependent on other people or things
factors outside of their control not
placing your desires there so if your
fundamental desire is to enjoy life with
your family and to have that go on you
know as long as possible you're probably
going to be disappointed
if your primary goal is to get super
high grades you know your entire college
career that may be a expectation that
just can't be fulfilled so if you choose
to put your your happiness there then
you will probably be unhappy
you'll probably be annoyed you'll
probably be irritated
what's a recent minor annoyance somebody
who hasn't said who's had a recent minor
annoyance okay that's so that's that's
very down-home sort of easy to relate to
kind of thing being stuck listening to a
conversation that probably doesn't need
to take place and doesn't have to take
place that way did you intervene in it
at all detach yourself from the
situation what would happen if you had
in here you think what made things
better
yeah and now you would have gotten even
more annoyed
well said something yeah change of foods
you mean in the cafeteria oh no because
your cafeteria is actually pretty good
alongside no you're right it's not home
if it's not and you're stuck with
whatever they happen to make that day
and you guys have a pretty wide range
yeah I imagine it must get boring after
a while okay so that's a good example
anybody had a big disappointment
and nobody wants to talk about their
bigness of payments how many did he had
to think of supplanted rather that was
skipped that lets preventatives and
thinking about this what we actually
have control
Epictetus is doing how thinks that he's
also doing just to go into a little bit
of you know his his philosophical
anthropology you notice he was making
reference to the rebels ruling cards or
Faculty of choice that's a rational part
remember we talked with Plato and
Aristotle both but you know part of us
is rash and all we can think things out
we were not just stuck with whatever our
reactions are and then we have all sorts
of desires and aversions appetite the
end for the swords also wondered what
are some of the emotions at the show on
a daily basis yeah happiness joy glad
yeah organism use kind of unrealistic
though like that you can't confine
anything because you probably be
disappointed there's some things that
you have to do and depending on other
things like you can't control them if
you have to do certain things I get yeah
so if he's gonna say no click batteries
forget it not going food and that's not
logical at all because you're gonna
you're gonna have to eat what they have
that yeah even let us say don't go to
marys because well you're gonna be
disappointed in some way so what he
would say is
what he would say is don't set yourself
up to be disappointed go to college and
then expect the food to be like what it
is Sophie thank you anyway
well kids that that's a good point and
as I was driving here I was thinking
about this because Epictetus just a
pessimist about things I can see how it
would seem that way that I'm actually
very sympathetic to that view myself I'm
not a story but I know a lot of people
who are at least thinking along these
lines and they don't all seem to be
radically unhappy in fact that the point
of it is to to free yourself to be
handling the idea is that by taking a
very we would probably call pessimism
they would say a very realistic
assessment of things you won't put your
desires and aversions into things that
you don't have control over so if you
want the particular going to the
cafeteria right any day you go to the
cafeteria you can go with a pasta bar
all right
so nothing else is good go to the pasta
bar this is the pastas necessarily going
to be good could be overcooked chef
who's who's back there mixing your vodka
sauce or marinara or you know I've seen
the things you guys yeah they could
screw it up they could cook under cook
it they could be they could cook it just
just right and they could be kind of a
jerk to you and they're handing it to
you and make you feel bad
there's all sorts of things that could
go wrong that patinas would say just be
aware of that and then you're not going
to be disappointed whether things that
actually do in fact is they want to do
go along it by the ways and by by sort
of short-circuiting you'll keep yourself
from well let's think about how things
go something minor happens you go back
to the table that's your fettuccine with
with marinara sauce you get back to the
table and you realize
you know I really wish I had Alfredo
okay do you let they actually get to you
some people would and then they'd obsess
about and then the small thing turns
into bigger and bigger and bigger or the
the chef was kind of a you know they
made it they they they look at you in a
way that you're not quite sure what it
meant when they well do you have any
control over whether people like you or
not a little bit yeah I mean if you if
you deliberately draw your way to be a
jerk you're probably guaranteed that
they won't like oh look maybe a third
the masochist into like [ __ ] right but
for the most part you don't have control
of it so if you can keep it as sort of
like detaching yourself and keeping
these things from slowly escalating into
bigger and bigger issues and that's by
choosing to do things differently than
how you've been doing them so far by
looking at yourself very carefully once
those look at nobody actually advise us
to do this
whatever more rules you've deliberately
proposed to yourself bide by them as if
they were laws so he's saying there
certain principles that you would put
into place and then you follow them and
each time you run into a situation that
looks like that sort of thing that it's
called for you follow that rule you
stick to that rule
but it may not make sense at first but
over time as this part becomes more and
more free see this print is able to
determine itself your desires your
designers are kind of blind emotions are
kind of like they didn't happen and
every time that you have an emotion it's
because of some reason but the part of
you that's getting emotional the part of
you that has desires of them gets
disappointed when it's desires are are
met or he has a virgin's and that gets
upset once you know it has to suffer
what it didn't want to suffer that part
means this other part ruling over it and
saying to hey you don't have control
over that don't don't you know I
understand that you feel you know
disappointed upset angry and all these
things but you don't have to feel that
way as a matter of fact the reason why
you're feeling that way is because
you've made some assumptions or even
made some judgments like for instance if
I get upset because the cook looked at
me in the wrong way I'm assuming that
it's that I have to be treated in a
certain planning is that a realistic
assumption that Partida suicide is there
anything the nature of things that says
that when somebody is serving me they
have to do so with a smile if I expect
that I'm going to be disappointing a lot
on time
yeah when I meet people for the first
time should I expect they're gonna like
me go do any of you expect people to you
know like you the first time they meet
you where they've got a million probably
unrealistic isn't it but you know you do
feel this is when you meet somebody they
don't like you well you have a choice in
how you look at that you could look at
it that's just the way things are
or you could you don't get upset about
it way things are it's not the way then
should the world should should conform
to your ideas on the phone
stubble system is about conforming
yourself to the way the windows so it
says remove the version from things that
are not in control transfer it to things
contrary to the nature of control if you
you're going to be adverse to something
be adverse to losing your temper be
adverse to letting things get to you
change what your averse to if you're
going to desire something instead of
placing your desires and the things that
up until that would make you happy place
them in getting control over yourself in
taking control over your life and
putting yourself on a path that will
actually lead you
tsa says work to be able to say to every
hardware hands every time you get the
situation where things seem like bad
work to be able to say to them you are
just an appearance and not absolutely
the thing that you appear to be with
regard to whatever objects give you
delight or are useful or deeply loved
remember to tell yourself what general
nature they are so I mean if you know
taking a nap it makes them feel good
remind yourself that taking a nap is
something that is easily broken and may
not make you feel good every time and
you're gonna be a lot less disappointed
right somebody breaks her siesta yes was
longer than yes it's shorter than four
hours what else does he time he does
talk about one other thing bring up
social roles and duties have you done
what you ought to do this is where we
get to say family stuff yeah it could
probably be good for you they're not
exactly what everybody else tells you it
should be you know I mean do that one
more time right that it should be
there's something that's beneficial for
you and not like what other people tell
you you should be doing that so I'm
guessing he's gonna say because you're
gonna be disappointed if you always live
by what other people tell you to do yeah
I think you're right and that epictetus
would say if you're gonna be a stoic you
should be a stoic because you see that
it's the right way to live not just
because
epictetus told
because you know you may actually find
out stoicism isn't for you and the
culture that we live in just like every
other culture tends to value some things
more highly than they ought to be valued
and presented as if they're easier to
get it easier to to hold on to the GAR
culture really stresses romantic moment
think about half of our movies have some
sort of love interest in them and often
central to the movie a lot of our songs
are about love and I know there's a
Valentine's Day and sweetest day is
there a time of year for like
engagements or things like that
follow that sort of stuff and I'm sure
some people now does romantic love make
most people happy in our culture
what's the divorce rate yeah I mean in
general is about 50 percent for your
generation of my generation it's over
50% dance with the marriages by the time
somebody actually gets married the
relationships that didn't work out quite
a few right I mean there are most people
waiting to get married and only dating
the person that they're going to marry
there's a few but not most he and then
actually that the odds are better for
those who do wait apparently
not sure why that is there's all sorts
of explanations so maybe maybe you know
listening to our culture about romantic
love is setting yourself up for a lot of
fun away in some heartache and grief and
to support them I mean you could
actually meet the person who's the one
for you you won't actually meet them if
you're not out there looking for for
somebody but if that's where you're
gonna place all of your happiness eggs
under that one basket it's kind of a
chance of gamble ISM do you have control
over whether the other person loves you
you could drive them away that's within
your control
can you make a person love you thank you
to it there probably is your mind for a
lot of disappointment so you want to you
want to stick to what you actually can
do going back to the social roles of
duties that all of you have certain
social roles based on what your family
what else is going into certain roles
you have one right now girl students you
have a choice whether to be a good
student or a bad student right you're
all training and I think to go somewhere
after this what are you planning on
doing after college
I don't think so all right what are you
planning on doing getting a job
something you're good at
yeah that's some sort of career and that
comes with all sorts of expectations of
roles so some of you are planning on
being pre-med you know if you become a
doctor the expectations of you're very
different than a train conductor or a
projectionist a movie theater
I suspect the doctor has a bit more
weight on their shoulders you know good
things exactly right a movie you know
the movie real doesn't go right that's
not that big of a deal if somebody's
operation is botched that is a big deal
is so all the view of these roles
Epictetus says you should fulfill your
roles you have to certain duties because
of them so you how many of you brothers
and sisters okay so you can relate to
him this example actually uses the
father but in another place he talks
about brother is it brother unjust so
how many dudes
how many have brothers and sisters won't
see you
how many never thought your your brother
or sister was mean to you or wasn't the
wrong and you were the right okay so
this is exactly what it's talking about
you're in that situation do you have a
key you have control over whether
they're a good person or not whether
they do the right thing you may have
tried to make them do it right to coerce
them how well did that work not very
well
mothers and fathers you could have a
good mother or a bad mother you could
have a good father a bad father that
doesn't affect you in so far as you have
your role it's up to you to choose
whether you want to be a good son or
daughter to be a good brother or sister
and you can do that even if they're a
bad mother or father
their sister to you I did say if you
expect them to be something that they're
not you're probably going to be very
unhappy very unhappy because family
stuff is you know one of the worse
things right that can really make us
unhappy family relationships romantic
relationships those get us much more
than work relationships or you know say
student professor relationships
if I don't like you that's very
different than your mom with dad what is
it plus one is much worse than the other
now I think he says are you naturally
entitled to a good father no you're only
entitled to have a father the way the
world works you have a parents the world
doesn't make them be good or bad parents
that's up to them and you don't have any
control over them so if you place your
happiness in them being good to you
you're going to be unfree you've made
yourself sort of like he says they're
slave because you've harnessed your
desires and you chose to do that on some
one of these sets you have the choice to
do otherwise you chose to make your
desires tie in with somebody else's
behavior that's making you up free if
you want to be free you have to choose
to change the way your desires good to
choose to change the way you think about
the situation so now here is where we
get to the part with the props how many
of you have heard stuff like this before
along these sort of likes you have a
choice in how you feel about things this
is part of our culture at least a
certain part of our culture in
psychotherapy this is what I've got this
this drop along right there's there's a
particular kind of psychotherapy called
cognitive behavioral therapy it's
actually one of the more effective ones
it had its part in epic Tina's the the
the reason I've got this one is the only
one I had handy on the shelf my uncle
gave
called feeling good by David Burns this
is the guy who popularized cognitive
behavior this is a best-seller and what
he tells you in there is if you're
feeling mad you're not feeling good you
have control over them you have some
degree of control over your emotions and
you can't control absolutely how you
feel but you can change the way that you
look at things and no longer feel say
angry or depressed or anxious or fearful
in this kind of situation of that kind
of situation because you can cut off all
these assumptions as they're taking
place can you do that all at once can
you snap your fingers and say I'm no
longer going to have an anger problem
and you do that with being sad can you
do that with not getting along with
people but you can change it over time
right
bit by bit and that is within your
faculty of choice you can't radically
remake who you are with just one choice
but by choosing over and over and over
again in a certain pattern you can
remake who you are and you can remove
how you feel and you can change your
basic approaches to things so that you
will be more free and happier so that's
one area psychotherapy where I'm
probably somehow self-help stuff where
stoicism has seeped into our culture I
brought another book along to yeah and
this is Tom Wolfe's a manifold probably
none of your brothers right it's a good
book to read this was a best-seller
years and years ago and the reason I got
it is because it has to do with
awesome and it also has to do with
something else that I'm interested in
prisons and guys in prison and what they
do and I'll tell you when I when I
taught in in Indiana State Prison and I
taught this material what do you think
these guys resonated with the most do
you think it was Plato or Aristotle it
was
Epictetus why do you think that was
pretty thing okay so you good today
well it's not just that they're a pretty
negative prison this is your life
history life is treated in that way so
they're so used to being disappointed by
things that's a good way to put it yeah
a lot of people wind up in prison
because they make a few you know bad
choices sometimes just once in a while
sometimes consistently and they often do
that in response to their life not being
the way they want to be the prison
environment itself is not a fun one to
live it it can range from just mildly
annoying to horrific depending on what
person you're in and what the other
people like and not just the gardens and
very usually the lease near problems so
if you're a prisoner who do you really
have to worry about you know the other
guys that you're intimate because they
didn't do nice things to begin there and
they didn't you know cast some sort of
the aptitude test to get out there they
did something usually pretty pretty bad
that's just the one I get caught for
they may have they may have done all
sorts of other things they may be the
kind of person who preys on other people
the living conditions are often very
unsanitary the health care is often
substandard the food is not very good
usually if you want to have your own
food you have to buy it at about three
market price and if you work a job in
prison you probably make anywhere from
10 to 35 cents an hour so and hidden you
if the little tiny cell next to a whole
bunch of other people who like like
probably jerks the guards can come in at
any time and search your cell or you to
strip-search you so it's not a nice
place to live why would stoicism be
attractive in an environment like that
because stoicism is about how to have
freedom in a world where you're
radically on free how to exercise that
little bit of freedom that you've got to
widen it a little bit each time that you
choose to change the way that you think
about things to change the way that you
desire so that you can get by so that
you can make it another famous
connection to the Epictetus and the
stoicism you guys probably haven't heard
of Admiral Stockdale because he was
famous about that's about twenty visit
20 years ago
yeah it's about 20 years ago he was Ross
Perot's running mate when Ross Perot ran
Admiral Stockdale did not do well
politically as a matter of fact he got
in a debate with I think it was Dan
Quayle
Al Gore and they just mop the floor with
the guy but he was a war hero and he had
been in a prisoner of war camp in
Vietnam for five years and those sort of
places make our prisons like a walk in
the park the sort of you know inhumane
treatment that he was experiencing just
every single day would have driven most
people insane and many people actually
did go insane or just died in these
camps what got him through was the fact
that in West Point he wrote about this
in West Point he had studied epic Tina's
and he had memorized the enchiridion and
why did he memorize it you know just you
know he admired somebody else who had
done this a lot of military people are
going to epic Tina's and when stoicism
and thinking through these things
allowed him to keep his sanity and to
keep from being very negatively affected
by the horrific treatment that he was at
home every single day so what I'd like
you to think about this is what I'd like
to leave you with and then I'm actually
going to talk a little bit about the
next reading that we're going to cuz
it's a bit different what I'd like to
leave you with this myth mr. Davis
brought up a really good point maybe
this is unrealistic or maybe this is a
philosophy that is only really
applicable when you're in bad situations
maybe Epictetus makes more sense than
worse your life is so think about that